Heidi Layton left Britain and came to
Germany long before anyone had ever
heard of brexit when I moved here and I
think for many people this was part of
the European Union you didn't really
feel like you were leaving your country
and now you feel like you're being made
to choose and that's 10 years in I mean
I have a life here counted as part of my
home she's a tour guide in Berlin she's
always out exploring on the lookout for
interesting and unusual things to show
visitors now she's wondering should I
stay or should I go but the moment I'm
more towards going back to the UK
initially I was more for staying I'm
doing intensive German lessons so that I
can have the opportunity to do a
residency visa or a you know citizenship
but it's difficult to make preparations
and plans one london-based company
that's beefed up its presence in Germany
is brick vest a real estate investment
outfit it opened its Berlin office one
month after the referendum on brexit its
German co-founder explains why it's also
access to qualified people has suffered
enormously many in London no longer feel
comfortable and fear they have no future
in Britain we're getting better people
and more people here in Berlin than we
did in London belong on Britain's in
Berlin fear their prospects are clouded
two years after the notification of
brexit the UK will be out of the EU
negotiations on the terms of the divorce
will be fiendishly difficult I teach
English to people whose first language
is in English and I have a job here but
it's I don't have a permanent contract
or a visa because I haven't needed it so
far so it may mean that I don't have a
job or I can't stay here but if I go
back to the UK and there's no EU
citizens that don't speak English then
my job prospects in the UK will be
massively diminished as well so it means
that I'm kind of stuck either way
these Brits in Berlin have set up a
group called forward Britain its
purposes as they put it to campaign for
a forward-looking Britain and a
forward-looking Europe during
negotiations and after brexit all of us
I think we're just more open and
forward-looking and international and
the whole point of calling ourselves
forward Britain was because we are
forward-looking people we don't want to
retreat to this kind of isolationist
protectionist existence which a lot of
people in not just the UK but other
other countries as well are falling to
this bread sued lived abroad for more
than 15 years couldn't vote in the
referendum many were angry their futures
in jeopardy but they couldn't exercise
what they consider their democratic
right we Brits abroad we felt very
frustrated that work that many of us did
not get to vote during the brexit and
you know with such as close call and
such a large amount of people who didn't
get their vote that's a really upsetting
part of this whole thing British expats
have difficult choices to make assuming
the terms of the divorce give them room
to make those choices
[Music]